foreign
you a first look at what's on the front
pages as they arrive in the next half an
hour we'll see what's making headlines
with Rachel cunliff Deputy online editor
of the new Statesman and Mary McLeod
chief executive of business in the
community so let's see what's on those
front pages
Rishi orders covered tests on arrival
from China that's the lead story in the
daily mail after the government
announced new flight restrictions that
story is also the need in the Daily
Telegraph and comes amid fears of a new
strain of covet emerging from China
the guardian too makes it its top story
the times also has it on the front page
but leads with news that the chief
medical officer so Chris witty is
worried that the pandemic has led to a
big increase in heart deaths because
people didn't get statins or blood
pressure medicines during lockdown
the New Year's on the list just
announces the lead for the mirror with
the headline Queen's honor for Queen
guitarist Brian May who is receiving a
Knighthood
the express claims an exclusive with a
report that more than 700 prisoners have
been wrongly released or escaped over
the last 10 years
the financial times reports that it's
been the worst year since the 2008
financial crisis for Global stock
markets with the war in Ukraine and
Rising interest rates wiping 30 trillion
dollars of the value of shares
and not long after one big freeze ended
the star tells us there's another one on
the way in January
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code that you see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch along with us well tonight says I
say we're joined by Rachel cunlift
Deputy online editor of the new
Statesman and by Mary McLeod chief
executive of business in the community
uh Mary Rachel good to have you both
with us this morning so let's kick off
Mary with youth with the Daily Mirror
and that is looking as we've been saying
at these new honors list
yes and this is the King's first New
Year honors list and what is always
lovely about those lists is that it is
about celebration and recognition and
allowing us to remind us of the
brilliant things that have been done
across the country in in the past year
and yes many of the main names are are
there that you'd expect like Brian me
and of course Denise Lewis and no one
would argue with with them getting the
recognition they've got for a lifetime
of Brilliance and but of course so many
others are whether it's a cross
Education Health Public Service science
business you know there are so many
others and especially around community
and voluntary service and those are the
stories that are always worth telling
and I think in times that are bad which
you know it's been a really tough year
and um and I think having those stories
of what people people have done some
amazing things inspire hire others to do
likewise so whether it's in a particular
field or whether it's in that Community
involuntary service which we saw so much
of during covert then it's absolutely
great that we can recognize that and
hear the stories of what all those
people have been doing because I do
think it will inspire others to do
volunteering and I just would encourage
everyone listening to recommend people
for these honors it's really important
that they're very diverse at the reach
out to all communities right across the
country and therefore do put people up
for it where you see just amazing things
happening on your doorstep well I'm
going to come back to you with some more
detail about that Mary and we'll talk to
you about some of the the previous work
you did I want to bring Rachel uh in
here now and Rachel let's look at the
front page of the Daily Star uh that's
of course in the sidebar they've got a
line about uh the honors list and about
Brian May but also a note there about
the lionesses four line s's got gongs
but the rest of the team didn't and
start saying the bit of a snub well
first I just want to Echo
of course
basically didn't volunteering and public
service and and that's really important
but I think the the headline story of
this honors list probably will be the
for honors awarded to uh four of them
England's women's football team who
obviously uh were the first England team
to to win a major football league
tournament um where they're winning the
Euros earlier this year which is
absolutely phenomenal I think you will
get a lot of people though asking why it
wasn't the whole wasn't the whole team
being honored uh I mean that the amount
that these women have done for women's
football for uh women's sport in general
the way they have just raised awareness
of of the game to a sort of national
level not to mention it being the the
first tournament in in 60 years where
where England has been successful that
was a team effort and there are women
who have been on that team who for uh
decades have been really putting the
work in when it comes to women's
football people like Jill Scott
um or in in indeed you know the the
woman who scored the winning goal
against Germany she's not one of those
sort of being honored and I just get the
sense that maybe he had the had it been
the men's team winning a a major
tournament the the Euros in 2021 for
example that final between England and
Italy you probably would see the whole
team being honored so there's a little
bit of a sour taste in the mouth even
though it is such a phenomenal
achievement for them and that was Chloe
Smith that we were talking about those
called that I'm winning gone I think
looking at England teams this has
happened before when the whole team has
been awarded I had a little read ahead
of this but you're right it probably
will be what lots of people were talking
about and Mary as I mentioned you you've
got some sort of insight into this
you're a former advisor to the Queens I
wonder what can you tell us about the
way these sort of things are decided you
said that uh people should nominate
those for honors but once it gets to the
Royal household what's the process there
well the king have signed off on all of
these
well I mean in essence there are 10 main
committees and there's no there's an
additional honors committee for
diversity to make sure that the honors
system reflects
um across UK Society so so you know you
do have Committees of her arts and media
education economy Community Health
Public Service science technology sport
State Etc so there really are you know
experienced people on those and
certainly if talking about Sport and
football and Sophie Robertson
um it's very experienced as chair of
that committee I mean his take I think
has been on it is that it was a European
tournament for the lionesses rather than
a World Tournament but I still you know
I I still think the lionesses are
changing the face of women's football
and it needs to be changed
um therefore you know I I do think it's
good that former recognize but but it is
a team sport and everyone helps each
other in that sex success so it'd be
nice to have seen more of them get a
recognition for for that because I think
also the time that the lionesses came
through for us we all felt it whether it
was people who loved football or didn't
but it just helped Britain feel better
um or certainly England feel better but
you know so I think it's just really
really um important as part of that in
terms of the process it um it goes
through those honors committees it then
gets reviewed and it would have to be
something quite extraordinary for
something to be pulled out and but
hopefully I mean if people put these um
a women forward again then they will
hopefully get something at some point in
the future yeah let's just take a look
at the front page of the Daily Telegraph
this is uh the England Captain Leo
Williamson there who who will be getting
honored uh and Rachel just a final
thought then uh from you on this as we
said it's the first awarding of the
honors list uh by King Charles and it's
a 50 women my understanding so I guess
that is is a step forward in terms of
the Honors that have been given out
it is a step
forward should have been honored in in
this case it is nice to be talking about
the positive impacts of these wars so
often when it comes to the honors list
we're tied up with the sort of political
issues of various special advisors or
people who back to the PM or didn't back
the PM uh getting awarded and it kind of
becomes tarnished by that and it is
important to focus on the positive side
of it and the significance of this being
the first list uh awarded by the new
king uh as Prince uh Charles did award
instead of these honestly stand in for
his mother on on multiple occasions uh
but just like with the the first King
speech that we had at Christmas we're
getting a lot of firsts and we're just
sort of slowly getting used to as a
nation having a king rather than a queen
and it's we're getting there I think
slowly recently our Rachel may stay with
us for now I'll be back with you in a
moment and we'll have plenty more from
the front pages of the mornings
newspaper including uh this story on the
front page of the daily mail saying that
the Prime Minister has ordered covert
tests for people leaving China
[Music]
if you are watching The Press preview
with Mia Rachel kunliff senior associate
editor of the new Statesman and Mary
McLeod chief executive of business in
the community Mary Rachel thanks for
sticking with us all right let's dive
straight into this story about new
restrictions being working for people
arriving into England from China let's
look at the front page of the Daily Mail
and uh Mary the male's saying that this
is rishi's decision to bring in these uh
pre-departure tests and also tests on
some passengers on arrival
yes and I think the I mean we're
following I guess the US Japan India and
Italy and then of course UK and France
and Spain are are adding those controls
on now I mean I think it is right to be
careful and and have the due diligence
around this I guess the main concerns
are some of the secrecy in Beijing
around the Dayton and understanding of
any new variants that are emerging from
China and again the government has tried
to base things on science and and
medical advice so I think the what
they're they're trying to do is say you
know we're not sure on what is happening
in in Beijing we're worried about those
concerns we're worrying about the Surge
and infections
um after they relax their tough pandemic
laws I think shanghai's had was it 5.43
positive million positive cases last
week so and there may be more that are
asymptomatic so they're just as we have
to still be careful we do not want
another lockdown in this country and but
that doesn't mean to say we could we
shouldn't be vigilant about what other
countries are doing and and anything
that could have a major impact in
infections in the UK yeah and Rachel
this was as Mary said it's been brought
in another number of other countries uh
prior to this it was always going to
come here I guess but it it did seem as
recently as yesterday that the
government was still kind of reviewing
it still not quite sure whether they
were going to bring it in
it's interesting isn't it I was doing
another paper review on Wednesday I
think and Italy and the US had just
announced that they were going to start
requiring a negative covert test for
arrivals from China now that was
Wednesday today's Friday and you can see
the um the the pressure on other
governments to to bring in these
restrictions now there is a point at
which we don't know how useful these
restrictions are going to be uh partly
because of the sort of high number of
asymptomatic cases uh because of it's
only relating to direct flights from
China obviously if you fly from China
somewhere else and then come to the UK
you wouldn't be tested and so there are
all kinds of reasons why it's not a sort
of fail-state strategy but I do think
that once Italy and the US said they
were going to it was kind of inevitable
that the rest of Europe
uh would would go further I mean there
have been calls from some uh European
politicians do you just ban arrivals
from China altogether it's all sort of
feels very Circa March 2020.
um the the fact is as sort of Mary
alluded to it's the lack of information
we don't know enough about the spread of
covert in China at the moment because
the Chinese government is not
necessarily being as transparent as it
could be it's pursued this zero covert
policy it has basically very Draconian
restrictions essentially locked down but
for much of the last three years they've
suddenly opened up cases are surging
their population is not as vaccinated as
other countries are suddenly people are
traveling again we don't know if it's
mutated we don't know what the risks are
and after the last three years I think
governments are right to be worried
whether or not we should feel more
secure because these restrictions have
come in is another matter yeah and let's
pick up on some of that um if we can
marry and look at the the front page of
the guide in their framing is a as a
U-turn by Rishi sunaka speaking to
Professor Paul Hunter earlier he said to
me that these restrictions might not
make any difference in kind of
controlling variants coming in and did
suggest this could be political I mean
what's your read on it how political is
it because obviously we should see like
very against bringing in any new
restrictions
yes but I think
I think it's on those coming into the
country which of course there might be
some Brits within that but you know we
all had to do it over the course of the
last
um years or during the covert times when
we were allowed to travel so it's not
unusual but I think there there is a
worry lots of other countries are doing
it so that might include pressure on the
government there's always still been a
public pool where the I think it's about
70 of the public are are backing this
and there's always fears about new
strains and you know there's huge
pressures on our NHS at the moment
especially in the winter time and
therefore I think that diligence and
been really you know really focused on
making sure there is no more further
um strains coming into the country of
course the UK government has to work
with the devolved governments too but
there are no direct flights from China
that go direct into Wales Scotland and
Northern Ireland but um but we'll
they'll still try and get
um similar policies there and to
volunteer rules yeah trying to get some
agreement across the involved Nations
all right let's look at the front page
of the times Rachel if we can and this
is a story by uh that's reporting on an
interview conversation with Chris witty
just just lay out for us what this is
and this is all about health and and
pressures on the service
areas of help
this is Chris witty saying that the
increase in deaths from heart disease is
partly a result of the pandemic which
interestingly is something that he said
right at the beginning before we even
went into lockdown I remember the
interview where he said we will see
excess death as a result of
um lockdowns that are imposed to to
reduce the spread of of covid and the
the argument is that during lockdowns
when people were
um encouraged to uh stay at home
obviously but also to not go see their
doctor unless it was an emergency people
didn't get diagnosed with conditions
which had they've been diagnosed with
them earlier they could be treated for
them so there is uh worry that people
who would have been ordinarily been
diagnosed and been prescribed medication
to deal with heart conditions also
indeed sort of cancer diagnosis and
cancer treatment those people didn't get
diagnosed they didn't turn up they
didn't want to put extra pressure on the
NHS at a time of covert they didn't want
to catch covert themselves and now it's
too late we're seeing excess death as a
result of that now obviously that's only
part of the story part of the story is
also how overloaded the NHS is
everything from a e to your GP to
everything in between and
um getting treatment and getting
diagnosed and making sure that the
process is working smoothly there are
problems at every stage of that at the
moment but I think it is significant
that Chris witty is sort of
acknowledging that our behavior during
covid may have led to to misdiagnosis
and we are seeing the impact of that now
okay uh Rachel Mary do you appreciate
your time this hour thank you very much
for being with us